everyone thinks that I'm just like
Monica but that's not true if you're
gonna put this in the tray set first of
all this is a counter spray I like to
have the dish soap oh my God Laura
please okay I love you honey let's call
this the one where Courtney Cox tries to
prove she's not like her friend's
character Monica Geller how did that
happen well it looks like it all started
when a fan made a comment saying she is
definitely Monica Geller everyone thinks
that I'm just like Monica but that's not
true Monica is a character that I played
you know the energetic obsessive
compulsive clean freak Court played on
the iconic series for 10 years
wow
I I see you move the green ottoman
but you know what just for fun let's see
what it looked like in the old spot
just to compare
let's see huh well it looks good there
too let's just leave it there for a
while yeah Courtney doesn't think she's
like Monica but her pal Laura Dern seems
to think otherwise one of many
characters that hold on one second
[Music]
no no I appreciate it oh look at her
so happy
if only there were a smaller one to
clean this one the actress frequently
gets nostalgic about her friends days
just remember it being such an amazing
time last year Court had some fun
transforming into her co-stars with the
friends filter on Instagram
oh it looks good with an earring or two
oh hello who is that
is that Monica not sure
Rachel
I have no idea this is one of the worst
apps I've ever seen but okay hello loot
my little Lisa cooge then a December
court photobombed fans the fountain
where the intro of the show was filmed
all right ready three two one
[Applause]
two one I'm sorry we're taking a photo
do you mind
whole thing was the best experience that
I could possibly imagine I felt very
lucky to have been a part of that show
and everything kind of seems to pale in
comparison whenever I read comedies I'm
just like Ugh
can't compare whether a court admits it
or not she'll always have a little
Monica shine through she already fluffed
that pillow Monica you know you already
it's fine Laura
did you face that first of all this is a
counter spray I like to have the dish
soap Monica she's uptight and I'm chill
so do we have that clear now thank you
foreign